selling concert tickets is not
especially hard
despite what your twenty dollar service
fee would suggest on a scale of
difficult problems to solve it lies
somewhere between light bulb
installation and check caching
the only remotely hard part you might
say a ticketing company's one job is to
handle the extremely predictable surge
of traffic the day Taylor Swift tickets
go on sale
so of course that's exactly what
Ticketmaster failed spectacularly at
during her most recent era's tour
pre-sale
traumatized fans told stories of 200
service fees cryptic error messages and
fifty thousand dollar seats
most left with nothing to show for their
eight hours of fighting in the trenches
others felt like lottery winners simply
for having been granted the privilege of
paying five six or nine hundred dollars
for nosebleeds
but although demand for this tour could
hardly have been higher there's nothing
new about the unpleasantness of buying
tickets
when service fees commonly cost more
than the actual seat it's no surprise
America's hatred of Ticketmaster makes
Comcast look favorable
how does the company get away with it
because Common Sense would say they can
Ticketmaster is so deeply embedded in
the industry that it's nearly impossible
for large artists to avoid
of Taylor Swift's 52 upcoming shows for
instance it sold the tickets for 47.
not only does it sell twice as many
tickets as its closest competitor
StubHub but it also represents
performers owns venues and acts as a
promoter
all of this is one hundred percent true
and yet it's not the reason service fees
are astronomical scalping is rampant or
buying tickets just generally sucks
sponsored by audible listen to
Ticketmasters the rise of the concert
industry and how the public got scalped
or one of thousands of other great
audiobooks for free with the link in the
description
what's the right price for a product
ask the seller and they'll tell you
that's easy the right price is the one
people are willing to pay
entire careers and disciplines exist for
the sole purpose of finding that number
with Penny precision
and because price has the largest impact
on profit more so than production costs
or even volume sold the science of
pricing has gotten pretty darn good
through surveys Trends and algorithms
companies systematically deconstruct the
value consumers place on each feature
a three dollar gallon of milk might
derive 30 cents of its value from being
reduced fat and a nickel from its
Packaging
they can then use those values to
determine the theoretical price of a new
product or a matrix of products with
different combinations of features
concerts on the other hand are just
about the opposite of milk
not only are they an experience but
they're also highly emotionally charged
besides no two shows are the same
Taylor Swift will only ever play the
eras tour in Kansas City on July 7th
once
now none of this would phase an
economist
after all there are many one-of-a-kind
products houses paintings and used cars
for example
when you don't know the consumer's
willingness to pay these simple econ 101
solution is to force them to reveal it
in other words an auction
all the technology required to double or
triple Taylor Swift's profit overnight
existed on eBay in 1995.
the problem of course is that artists
are in the business of cultivating
Goodwill
these higher prices would effectively
exclude many of their biggest fans
bruising their image and limiting the
long-term growth of their fan base
take a second to appreciate what this
means
instead artists artificially price their
tickets hundreds or even thousands of
dollars below market value
we know this because the same tickets
are immediately resold for many
multiples of their original price
remember from a purely economic
perspective the right price is the one
people are willing to pay
and a natural consequence is the
opportunity for scalpers to buy low and
sell High
if Taylor Swift won't charge what she's
worth some random dude in Romania is
more than happy to do it for her
at the same time artists are also in the
business of making money
they still want to capture some of that
extra value
and one of the ways they balance these
two competing interests is by secretly
withholding many of their best seats
some of these holds may be given to
friends and family
others however are sold directly to
brokers who turn around and sell them to
you at the prevailing market rate
in 2011 Katy Perry's contract was leaked
to the public revealing that she like
many musicians did just that
in other words artists get to have their
cake and eat it too protecting their
image with affordable primary ticket
sales while profiting off a far more
expensive secondary sales
now you might argue that artists
themselves are victims of the larger
industry one they have no choice but to
participate in
this is true
unless Taylor Swift wants to play for
crowds of 800 people at the Timbuktu
County Fair Ticketmaster is effectively
the only game in town
that's because it signs three to five
year exclusive contracts with the vast
majority of large desirable venues
all the star power of Sinatra Elvis and
Lenin combined would be worthless
against these airtight contracts
if you want to play at these venues
which for the most popular artists
really means play at all Ticketmaster
comes with them
but what critics of the company often
miss by fixating on its Monopoly is the
question why
why do companies sign these exclusive
deals with Ticketmaster
Once Upon a Time ticketing was a cost
for venues a service like security that
they outsourced to the lowest bidder
what Ticketmaster did its Innovation if
you can call it that was approach these
venues with an offer What If instead of
you paying us we paid you
sure part of the reason Ticketmaster got
so big was by swallowing up its
competitors but it also did so by
promising to make concert venues more
money
for cash-strapped public stadiums
especially this guaranteed source of
Revenue proved irresistible
it did this with the two most hated
words in the English language service
fees
every show was different but these fees
are typically shared between some
combination of Ticketmaster the venue
promoter and or artist
the truth though it pains me to say this
is that the vast majority of
Ticketmasters customers love it it's
just that we are not its customers
we are just collateral damage caught in
a web of intermediaries fighting to
capture the value of live music
that's what the justice department
decided in 1995 after a years-long
investigation that its true customers
were perfectly happy with the status quo
a decade later a federal district court
in California reached the same
conclusion
there's no doubt Ticketmaster wields far
more control than any one company should
have over the music industry
in fact since it merged with Live Nation
in 2010 Ticketmaster itself owns many of
the venues that granted exclusivity
these things are easy to understand
what's not as well understood is that
greater competition isn't in this case
an effective solution
remember ticketing companies compete to
give more money to venues in the form of
service fees
split Ticketmaster in two and they would
bid service fees up not down
yes the company's vertical integration
spanning venues promotion ticketing and
managing is incredibly concerning
but let's not forget that it had no
trouble securing these exclusive
contracts well before it merged with
Live Nation in 2010.
in 1994 for instance it had exclusive
deals with 63 percent of American Arenas
and concert Halls
now if any of this surprised you that's
the point
if you assumed service fees were
entirely the fault of Ticketmaster you
are proof that the company doesn't just
skim profit it also offers a valuable
service
what's Ticketmaster is is a reputational
shield
ticketing is the ugly part of the
business the business part of the
business
so artists who don't want to touch it
with a 10-foot pole Outsource it
the implicit agreement is that while
fees get spread around Ticketmaster
alone takes the hit
and when fans can't get seats it's
Ticketmaster who delivers the bad news
but the critical thing to not lose sight
of is that above all these
intermediaries is the only absolute
unbreakable Monopoly the artist
though he may be on all our iPhones
there's only one Bono
the top one percent of artists negotiate
from a position of extraordinary
strength this may sound like an obvious
truism the most popular artists are
powerful duh but it's something fans in
their eagerness to forgive their Heroes
often forget
consider for instance how they get paid
artists through their agents who
typically take a percentage of their
earnings are approached by a promoter
promoters are the heart of the whole
operation Beyond managing scheduling and
yes promoting by far their most
important role is to underwrite the
events
while artists receive a guarantee an
upfront fee for their performance say a
million dollars the promoter may make
more than a million dollars or they may
make far less they assume that risk
the most popular musicians confident in
their ability to attract crowds often
choose a percentage of the door instead
and the higher their guarantee or
percentage the less money is left over
for everyone else
when top artists can demand as much as
105 more than the total ticket sales
it's no wonder these costs eventually
Ripple down to you and I in the form of
twelve dollar pretzels and fifty dollar
service fees it had to come from
somewhere
and that's just one part of the contract
musicians also help determine ticket
prices fees pre-sale requirements and
whether or not to use Dynamic pricing
which adjusts prices algorithmically
this is not at all to paint artists as
the villains and Ticketmaster as an
innocent scapegoat they're all complicit
to varying degrees
but if your goal is to affect change
calling for the breakup of Ticketmaster
is more a satisfying method of venting
frustration than it is an effective
solution
the real hope lies with the artist the
party both with the most power and the
one most responsive to fans
it may not be the musician's fault that
the industry is what it is but if anyone
can negotiate on behalf of all of us
it's Taylor Swift who in 2015 almost a
single-handedly changed how artists are
paid on Apple music and more recently
fought back against her own record label
just as the costs imposed by the top one
percent of artists Ripple down to the
rest of us these privileged few can also
set better terms that benefit everyone
music history is filled with exactly
that bands standing up for their fans
sometimes the borderline comical degrees
when the jam band The String Cheese
Incident was refused the right to sell
its own tickets in the early 2000s it
threatened to hand out cash to thousands
of volunteers who would go buy them on
their behalf at the box office which was
exempt from service fees
The Grateful Dead likewise font
Ticketmaster for the right to sell half
its tickets directly to fans
in order to prevent scalpers from buying
more than the permitted number of
tickets it would spread thousands of
order slips on the floor and look for
duplicate handwriting
plus other stories I learned while
reading Ticket Masters the rise of the
concert industry and how the public got
scalped which you can listen to on
today's sponsor Audible
it tells the full fascinating story of
how ticketing went from a system of
regional monopolies maintained by
promoters to the modern online Monopoly
we know today
along the way you learn things like why
one of Ticketmaster's first customers
was the Norwegian government who wanted
to design a more Equitable socialized
distribution of tickets
now the worst feeling in the world is
getting a chapter into a book realizing
it's not really for you and feeling like
you have to keep reading the reason I
love audible is that you can always
return a book and choose a new one I've
done it probably a dozen times
with an audible membership you get one
credit a month to listen to any of its
thousands of great audiobooks they also
have exclusive shows and podcasts
visit audible.com polymatter click the
link in the description or text
polymatter to 500-500 that's
p-o-l-y-m-a-t-t-e-r-2500-500 to get one
free audiobook of your choice and start
listening today